you can change the negative patterns
that I run in your life the patterns
that you think are impossible to break
that have been with you for life that
will be with you for the rest of your
life you can break them it starts with a
decision and if you don't want to still
be in 20 years living by that same
negative pattern that is holding you
back most of what we do is subconscious
most of what we do is beneath the
surface most of what we do is what we've
been conditioned to do and the patterns
that we've seen and you know if you're
watching this you're likely an adult and
we've been running the same pattern
programming for a number of years if not
decades and it can be really difficult
to be able to switch that pattern but
I'm going to give you a formula today
that I think will really help and one
that I'm applying myself as well in my
life
get a mentor hey it's Nina Carmichael
and we made these videos probably
because you're the most ambitious person
in your circle but you know you're
capable of much more and you get that
Push by surround yourself with the best
so today let's learn from one of the
best my husband Evan Carmichael and
learn how to change the negative
patterns that are ruining your life
enjoy
so step one
is even just acknowledging that the
pattern exists and that you want to make
a change
what is to happen what is the negative
Loop that's in your mind what is the
thing that you don't want to still be
thinking
in the next year two years five years
ten years what is that thing one of the
things that I'm working on is moving to
a space of great things happen to me I
had a great video uh coaching session
with Beth hendel and my big aha moment
that came from there was
I believe in the plan
so whenever I am thinking of something I
make a plan and then I execute the plan
and I do the plan and I follow the plan
and when I don't believe in the plan
then I create a new plan that I believe
in that plan and that's the thing that
gets me going so I'm very plain schedule
calendar oriented that gives me my
security that gives me my identity and
so as long as I have a plan easy peasy
let's go waking up we're making videos
because it's in the plan
but then what happens on the rare days
you know maybe once a month where
I don't believe in the plan anymore I
don't think the plan is good enough to
get to where I want to go
and I can't make a new plan I don't know
what the next plan should be what I have
done so that I don't get lost and
spiraled down into negative thinking
into uh maybe not depression but
um anxiety and stress and overwhelm that
I don't know what to do next you ever
been faced with that like I don't know
what to do next
my plan has been my plan see I'm using
the words
just to tell myself
great things happen to me this is what
I've done it's been my coping mechanism
the the way out of the stress and the
anxiety and not knowing what to do next
is me telling myself great things happen
to me
and what Beth challenged me to do
and the big Insight that came from it
was living not in the identity of the
plan but living in the great things
happened to me so now I'm trying to
shift my identity from being the guy who
believes in the plan to being the guy
who believes that great things happen to
me that instead of using great things
happen to me just as a coping mechanism
on my worst days the once a month days
when I really don't believe that I'm I'm
getting closer to my goals or I'm never
going to hit them
and flipping that to being the default
mode that's that's really hard I've I've
was not born the plan guy it took me
decades I'm 42 coming up in May I'm 42
and it took me decades to become the
plan guy you know two decades to become
the planned guy
and now I'm I'm not
getting rid of the plan guy thank you
plan guy you got me here I appreciate
you you know Pat in the back I still
need you please stay with me on this
journey but I want to be the guy who
believes the great things are coming
because at the end of the day all your
great things all your great ideas all
your great breakthroughs usually don't
come as a result of the plan
it's a maybe a byproduct of the plan but
not a direct result of the plan because
the plan only is something that you know
exists right now it's it's what I've
talked about making decisions with your
head versus your heart big decision with
your heart song with the head the head
only understands the world that
currently exists where your heart can
create something brand new and so I want
to be I want to be in the brand new I
want to create something that hasn't
been done before and so the you can't
plan for something that hasn't been done
before and you need to have some faith
that great things will happen and so
that's a long way of me saying that I am
trying to become
the guy who believes that great things
happen to me as a default state
I believe that when I say that when I
create video and I say that on camera or
when I'm talking I believe that I
believe the great things come to me if I
keep going if I keep making if I keep
sharing if I leave with my heart if I
tap into what I feel is the right thing
to do even if it doesn't make sense I
believe that great things will happen
and I've seen enough of that happen over
my life and career that I believe it and
if you're not quite there yet
just look for some small wins that when
you have help when you have shared when
you have created from the heart you've
gotten some small wins and if you keep
going you can have
slightly bigger ones and medium-sized
ones and then large ones and then
gigantic wins if you just keep going so
how do I shift and we're working through
this in real time I'm not sharing a
story that is you know it's 20 years old
like I sometimes might do the foundation
story so how do I shift how do I shift
from being
the plan guy to the great things will
happen to mikai I think it could be
useful
Mini case study for you if there's
something that you want to work on
that you want to improve at you're tired
of telling yourself a different story
and you want to shift it so here's what
I'm doing first off is trigger words
right so if I say plan that's a trigger
word plan ooh plan here's my plan like
oof plan I said it again not that it's
bad right for years it might be bad it
might be it might be a critical you
telling yourself that you're stupid or
that you can't or it can't it could be
another a trigger word or hard it's
another trigger word the fact that
you're not going to do something because
it's hard that's a trigger word right so
what are the trigger words that you tell
yourself as to why you can't do
something or that keep you locked in
your negative patterns what are those
trigger words that anytime you catch it
you say it you feel it you tell somebody
else it that like oh there it is again
I'm noticing it and you can tell the
people in your life your your family
your friends your spouse people on your
team you can tell them hey if I ever say
this word I want you to I want you to
call me out in it so you can have people
kind of support you through this journey
as well number two is you try to design
in a conscious way
applying it in your life consistently so
the next thing I did as soon as I got
off that coaching call with Beth was I
told Nina I told my wife and I said hey
great things happen to us I told her
what happened and great things happened
to us great things happened to us great
things happen to us and I honestly I
must say that at least 40 times a day
great things happen to me I'm talking to
myself or great things happen to us
if you want you can set it as a alarm in
your phone you could put it as a
background on your on your computer
screen you can put it as a sticky note
on the bathroom mirror or the door I
have a email that I sent myself that I
didn't delete out of my inbox so so I
always see it in my inbox every day when
I'm checking my email I check my email
once a day and it's always the last
email that I that I checked because I
never removed from my inbox and it says
this is your great things happen to
reminders
this is your great things happen you
reminder every time oh that's right
great things happen to me because that's
still not it's nowhere close to being my
default
but I'm working towards becoming that
person
so it's the decision to do it and then
with intention putting things into your
calendar so that it happens so again
maybe you're setting an alarm on your
phone maybe you're putting the picture
up on your wall you're telling your
friends and the people around you and
you're finding a way to repeat it to
repeat it to repeat it to repeat it and
I'm not judging myself as to I need to
get this done next week
I just want to make a little bit of
progress every day Beth's team reached
out and wanted to do a round two of
coaching and I said I'm still I mean
thank you it's amazing I'm still working
on the last thing you know the great
things happen to me
shift in mindset is something that I'm
working through and
it's incredibly powerful and I don't
think I need any help for anything else
yet I'm still working through this thing
this week has been a really challenging
week for anina and myself as well we are
we ran our build to serve challenge
which which was crazy
um when we first did it the the idea
that was pitched to me was seven days 45
minutes to an hour each day and we ended
up going the seven days and you know
three to four hours each day which I
didn't budget for but it was amazing
helping thought leaders and speakers and
coaches and entrepreneurs authors
just the energy and the vibe and the
love was so amazing that it took up an
incredible amount of time at the same
time we just bought a a brand new house
which is super exciting and so selling
this place and so I had to move my app
you might notice it's a different
background than usual I'm not I guess I
could have done it in my car
um but I'm not in my usual Studio my
office because we have a makeshift
office while we get our place ready to
list today
so we're packing and moving and
switching all the artwork and all of
that stuff while running a challenge uh
yesterday I hit the side of a a curb
that had a rock
not a rock like a boulder and it
punctured my tire and not just like
giant hole in my tire uh so okay we have
to go and get the car fixed on top of
everything else which is why I can't
film in the in the car like I normally
do because I don't have a car right now
because it's being fixed because we I
blew out the tire and just issue over
issue over issue and
my niece was with us yesterday
and she made a comment to my wife Nina
about how calm we were through
everything like okay well the car tire
got blown out uh that's that completely
changes how we spend the rest of today
now instead of doing these errands and
taking people here and all of this stuff
uh on Nina's birthday by the way
it's like okay well here's what we need
to do now you know okay we gotta get it
fixed we gotta figure out how to solve
these other problems and let's go and
she was my niece was blown away but how
we weren't arguing or fighting or
yelling or
uh super stressed just okay let's solve
the problem and keep moving around with
our day why because great things happen
to us
great things happen to us and that's you
know when something negative going on
even if it doesn't feel real
it'll be something that Nina and I will
laugh over great things happen to us oh
that happened okay great great thing you
know what great things happen to us
figure out a way through this great
things happen to us and in that ongoing
conditioning
the more that it's around us the more
that I say it I believe it a little bit
more and a little bit more and a little
bit more and a little bit more and I
guess you could call it affirmations I I
never really
connected to affirmations that much
because it felt
if I was saying something that I didn't
believe in that
that it wouldn't it wouldn't work for me
and because I already believed that it
wouldn't work for me then I've already
set myself up for feeling from the
beginning I think the key thing is if
you want to be able to change that
mindset you want to change the Habit
Loop you have to find something that you
actually on your best days believe
there's a kernel of Truth in there right
if you're 400 pounds and you say I'm
skinny I'm skinny I'm skinny I think I
think a lot of
in your head you say well that's BS I'm
not skinny and and then you don't
there's no even kernel of truth to it so
then you never do the actions to help
you get there where on your best days
when you believe about yourself on your
best days how do you handle problems
so when I say great things happen to me
I believe it
I actually believe that that wasn't
something that was given to me that
wasn't something that somebody once told
me that wasn't somebody that a coach
told me that okay you have to use this
now as your Mantra I believe it on my
best days I believe it I believe it I
can I can tap into that and I believe it
there's a kernel of truth to it and I
want to make that kernel you know grow
into something much much much much
bigger so homework would be to think
about
on your best days what do you believe
about yourself what what's the specific
language the specific words that you
would say to yourself to encourage
yourself or you're looking back and
you're proud of yourself on your best
days what do you believe about yourself
and then finding a way to make that a
daily part of your life
so that when the negative things come
you can tell yourself this as a reminder
and starts to shift everything for you
rule number two model success the
fastest for you to get to success
there is to model success yes the idea
here is simple you find people who have
already done the thing that you want to
do learn from them understand what they
did to get there and then try on their
hat right see what worked for them and
apply it to your business this is what
worked for me this is what saved my
company Bill Gates saved my first
company even though I've never met him I
haven't yet we're going to make it
happen hopefully hopefully hopefully
soon
I was struggling I had a upstart
software company that wasn't making
money and I quit on my business partner
and I woke up the next day and said I
need to find a way to make this happen
like I can't quit on this too soon
because I'm going to regret it if I
don't keep going and so I said who has
done this before who's done this and I
thought of Bill Gates was the first
person that came to mind was Bill Gates
I looked at his story and how did he
build Microsoft well through
Partnerships and so I started making
Partnerships in my business I had
nothing else to lose I was already at
rock bottom right I didn't quit on my
partner it was hopeless so let's just
give this a shot and within I don't know
a couple months maybe even sooner I
landed my first partnership deal for
thirteen and a half thousand dollars and
at the time guys I was making 300 bucks
a month so that money meant the world to
me like that was that was bank and and
more important than that it it gave me
hope you know like this could happen
this this business could actually work
and it gave me a model to then go and do
it again and again and again and ever
since then whenever I don't know what to
do on model success I find someone who's
done it and I try to apply their
strategies and make it work for me but
this is the important thing not every
strategy is going to work the same way
for them as it did for you
so maybe waking up early is your ticket
maybe waking up later is going to be
your ticket there's people who've done
both which is the one that's going to
work for you you won't know by sitting
on the couch and thinking about it the
best thing you can do is just go and try
you try on their hat right Bill Gates
did this Dan Lok does this Bruce Lee
does this awesome try it try it and see
people prejudge so early
you have to change your habits if you
want to get something more than you have
right now it's because you're doing
something different than what you're
doing right now and different is scary
different means you don't know what's
going to work out or not different is
different we don't want to do different
right you want to stay inside our
comfort zone that's not what your
success is going to come but not
everything you try is going to work even
the ones that do work won't work 100
percent
Jade said Partnerships and his business
is different than the way that I did it
but just that idea alone took me 80 of
the way modeling success takes you
eighty percent of the way and then that
final 20 is you gotta make the
adjustments to make it your own because
otherwise you just end up being a junior
version of somebody else instead of
being you
but I think we're too often just judging
people you're judging the strategy
saying well that's not going to work for
me without even trying it and so I have
this channel where you can learn from
people every day I have my top 10 rules
where you can watch those videos and
learn from people every day if you watch
a top 10 video These are 10 rules for
some of the most successful people on
the planet in the history of humanity
here they are with 10 different lessons
not all of those 10 lessons have to work
for you have to apply to you take one of
them take two of them and just do
something just apply it to your life
apply it to your business and see if you
get a result that's the key and so you
need to get out of your head you need to
get out of your own way and you need to
just start doing the best thing you can
do is go from idea to action when you
see something that kind of makes sense
that might be a fit for you just start
doing it stop judging start doing it and
apply it to your business and see if it
works give it a shot also to make sure
you're actually taking action after
watching this video I've designed a
special free worksheet just for this
video the worksheet will highlight all
the Lessons Learned in this video as
well as pull out our three favorite
learnings and quotes that will inspire
you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet design specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business I'll see you
there
number three ignore bad advice
who are telling you that your idea won't
work are not the people whose life that
you want so why are you listening to
them your Uncle Joe your Aunt Susan the
rest of your family the people who you
grew up with from high school look at
their life look at their life right now
take away their words and what they're
telling you remove the emotion from it
look at their life do you want a life
like theirs because their advice will
lead to a life like theirs if not then
you probably should be doing the exact
opposite of what they're telling you to
do now I think there's two types of
people who will give you negative
feedback you got the haters and then you
got the people who are just ignorant and
there's a big difference between those
two so let's start with the haters the
haters I call the little man the haters
their entire role and their life is to
bring other people down maybe they took
their shock this is actually quite
frequent they took their shot they tried
they didn't work they failed and so now
nobody around them can be successful
they get their value they get their
self-love by destroying other people
because it makes them feel better about
themselves it's like watching some train
wreck on reality TV show right watching
relationships and lives fall apart
because it makes you feel better about
your life you feel better about your
life when you see somebody else's life
be a total mess right those are the
haters now how do you deal with them it
starts by understanding that
if you believe like I believe that
humans are built to serve right people
are built to serve you want to do good
people are good right both of those
things humans are good and we're built
to serve then what would get somebody
who is good and built to serve to leave
a nasty negative comment or to tell you
that you suck or your deal is not going
to work out what would drive them to
doing
they really hate their life
right like empathy is the first step
just feeling bad for them not not
sympathy and and using that as a
negative against them not saying well
your life sucks so I'm not gonna that
that's not gonna help anything it's
actual genuine empathy if the highlight
of somebody's day is coming to this
video and leaving a negative comment
it's okay I feel bad for that person
if that's the highlight of your day then
you must be in a really rough spot if
you're if you believe that people are
good and they're built to serve and so
what that does is remove the sting out
of the comment when somebody is Raging
on you
that that you suck and that your idea is
never going to work having empathy to
understand wow this person is likely in
a really tough spot
that removes the sting of the words and
allows you to then be more
practical less emotional to respond
emotionally and feel like oh my God
maybe they're right maybe they have a
point maybe I do suck say wait wait a
minute wait a minute this person they
hate their life why am I listening to
them right just like the wake-up call
out of the the head game that you're in
listen to their advice so those are the
haters remove the sting and then allow
you to make a practical decision the
second part are the people who are
ignorant they're your friends your
family the people around you who they
actually love you right chances are your
parents love you your mom probably loves
you right most moms love their kids your
parents probably love you so why would
they be telling you not to go do
something why would why would they be
telling you advice against what you want
to hear
because they grew up in a different era
your parents are pilgrims your parents
don't understand a world that exists
your parents don't understand that you
can have a full-time business from this
it doesn't make sense when your parents
were your age they couldn't do the
things that you can do
so they want you to be successful the
people around you who love you want you
to be successful they have a different
definition of success
success to them looks different than it
does for you because they're from a
different era and that's okay again
starting point is empathy understand
that these words that are coming out of
their mouth is love they're trying to
express love their concerned for you
they want you to win they just have a
different version of what winning looks
like and so
when you're dealing with with parents or
friends or family chances are the thing
that you're great at Michael Jordan
level Talent at the thing that you want
is not the thing that your family does
and so it takes a lot of courage and
strength to say here's what my family
does here's what my community does
here's what my friends are doing I want
to be doing this
that's hard that takes a lot of strength
and courage and then these people they
don't want to see you go off and do that
because they want you to stay here they
want you to stay in their Community what
does it say about them if you're off
doing something else right it's their
own fears and insecurities because if
you go off and have success over here it
makes them feel bad about themselves
they start to doubt themselves on what
they're doing they don't want to do that
so having empathy right understanding
that and then especially of dealing with
parents I'm going harder on the parents
because I get so many entrepreneurs who
are who are asking me about how to deal
with my parents
when you are trying to pitch your idea
and say here's what I want to do
and you are absolutely convinced that
it's gonna work guess what's gonna
happen your parents are the people who
love you will double down on why it's
not the thing to do
if you say I'm gonna go be a YouTuber
right
great I want to be a full-time YouTuber
and you can say well look at all these
people who've had successful careers as
full-time YouTubers
you go tell them that they can say
that's crazy don't be a YouTuber you go
get a job go be a lawyer like that's the
safe that's stable go into real estate
that's what you should be doing don't
don't go be a YouTuber that's crazy
the more certain you are in it the more
they're gonna think you're crazy and
they're gonna Double Down On It
the more you think of of course it's
gonna work out what are you talking
about why don't you support me right if
you're fighting why don't you love me
why don't you support me why don't you
why don't you encourage me
look at all these people having success
of course I can do it what don't you
believe in me the more you attack them
and are certain in your position the
more they're going to build up their
walls and be more certain their position
because they think this this person
doesn't understand what's happening
this person is so blind how do you not
see this thing
on the other hand if you approached it
from a softer side if you said
listen I don't know if it's gonna work
out I know a lot of people trying and
don't work out in business a lot of a
lot of entrepreneurs never make it I'm
afraid that it won't work
but I have to try
I have to try because I know that if I
don't try I'm gonna regret it I'm gonna
get to the end of my life and I'm gonna
regret not having taken my shot and I
don't want to look back on my life and
say this is my moment to try and I was
too afraid I don't want to be afraid
I would rather know and fail than not
know and I'm scared
I hope you can understand that and
support that
that's a lot easier for somebody to come
down and say okay I understand
you're not attacking them
you're leaning on vulnerability and and
your fears and insecurities more than on
certainty that this is going to work
and it's likely going to lead to a much
healthier relationship and healthier
conversation now it doesn't mean that
they're automatically going to accept
you and yes that's what you're going to
do
and then you have to decide are you
going to live your life or your parents
version of your life
your family's version of your life your
community's version of your life when
you when you get to decide that it's
your life
when you're four years old you don't
have a choice right you do what your
parents tell you to do
when you become an adult though what is
it 14 is it 16 is it 20 is it 25 is it
32 are you going to be 50 and still
doing what your parents want you to do
like at what at what age you get to
decide are you gonna say this is my life
and I'm gonna I'm gonna live my life and
if people support me great and if not
I'm going to be an army of one and I'm
going to will it into existence
so if you're an entrepreneur doing crazy
amazing things you got this Vision you
want to change the world you want to
serve you want to have an impact you
want to make money
you're going to be faced with a lot of
people who criticize you because you
want to disrupt the status quo do
something different there's a lot of
people who don't want you to do
something different they like the status
quo they want you to just fit inside the
status quo fit inside this perfect
puzzle piece sit in your box and you're
good to go right A lot of people want
that for you
[Music]
and over that course of you building
your amazing dream business you're gonna
get faced with both kinds of people
giving you negative feedback the haters
and the people who are just ignorant
and learning to start with empathy
understand where they're coming from
and then deal with it in a way that is
empowering using the strategies they
gave you
will give you more confidence and
courage and positivity and energy and
optimism to move forward because you
need it because building a business is
crazy tough crazy hard and you need all
the support you can get and if at the
end of the day you still have nobody who
supports you you can come on back to
believe Nation because we're here every
day there's a lot of love for me but
also you guys in the comments in the
community you can share your thoughts
share what you're going through and
chances are you have somebody who will
help you who will be a guiding support
who will listen to you and support you
as well rule number four don't tie
yourself worth two
you're afraid of experimenting because
you tie yourself forth to winning
instead of trying if you base your
self-worth off how much you win then
you're only going to try things that you
have a good chance of winning that thus
you play small for life but instead if
you base yourself forth on trying on the
effort that you're putting in you will
fail on most days but you'll end up
accomplishing more than you ever thought
was possible so every time I go to our
YouTube event I'm always being praised
by my thumbnails people always say
Evan's got the best thumbnails go look
at his thumbnails model his thumbnails
use them as an example for the best
practice and I I internally am always
saying our thumbnails suck we need to
get better sure we might be among the
best but we need to get better we can be
way better than we are right now
why have we become the best
because I'm experimenting constantly
most of my tests do not work I use a
tool called tubebuddy shout out
tubebuddy huge fan we've done over 1100
split tests on our thumbnails where we
won one thumbnail against another and
one against another and one against
another trying to beat our best and most
of the experiments don't work they just
don't work I recently ran an experiment
of on my main Channel putting my face on
the thumbnail with the Youtube white
border against Tony Robbins and it
tanked it was like 80 percent worse than
our current thumbnail and that's okay
people don't like my face next to Tony
ruins that is okay I'm fine with it I
expect to lose I expect everything I do
not to work but I'm willing to test it
to see I just recently came up with one
thumbnail design where I made the
background purple instead of black
purple instead of black and it actually
did better it did significantly better
and so now I'm testing it out on five
more thumbnails to see does the purple
one do better than the black one if that
works out maybe I rolled it out across
the entire Channel but it's very rare
that I find the win
out of the 1100 experiments that we've
done most of them will not work will
never work even from the beginning I'm
thinking this is probably not going to
work but I'm willing to test that's okay
even if the most likely outcome is
failure it's worth the test to see I
think we've been conditioned so much
that failing is bad that when you fail
you suck and everybody ridicules you and
and then that's the end the people who
have won the most have failed the most
Jeff Bezos has failed the most he's
tried so many things and most of them do
not work out and that's fine people
don't see the losses when you've got a
couple wins under your belt how do you
get to the wins through all the losses
right most people they take one bet they
lose because you don't know what you're
doing the first time out you lose and
then you never get back and do it again
you never get up and try again you
settle for a mediocre life because
you're not meant to be an entrepreneur
you're not meant to be a expert you can
never make it and you tell their story
to yourself you just failed once that's
all you should you should suck at the
beginning most things should fail at the
beginning if you start studying success
and I've studied more successful people
than most people you'll see that it's a
history of losses and failures and
defeats in the micro
that then they learn from and they find
one thing that works and then they push
all their chips in and go all in on that
thing that's the only difference they're
not any more special than you they just
are more willing to experiment to try
and to fail now I've got a three-step
process to help you experiment more and
stop caring so much what other people
think that I think will help step number
one is expect to suck at the start
expect to suck
crazy how people expect to be great the
first time out the first thumbnail that
you're you're gonna make is gonna suck
the first person that you hire on your
team is gonna suck not because they suck
it's because you suck as a manager as a
trainer as a leader in hiring you suck
it's your fault look at most companies
and look at the first 10 people that
they hired big companies those 10 people
aren't around anymore because the
entrepreneur found they're sucked at
hiring you will hire the wrong person it
doesn't mean that you can never hire
people or you should always be a solo
entrepreneur you just don't have that
skill set yet okay awesome the first
video that you make will suck go back
and watch my first videos they all
sucked I was completely embarrassed by
the first 350 public videos on my
channel completely embarrassed could not
watch them back ever awesome keep going
you're going to step up to the free
throw line and try to shoot a basketball
you're not gonna get it in the first
time you just won't I think actually if
you're great the first time out then you
actually suck like if you get on camera
you make your first video
and you're great you suck you should
have started four years ago you should
have started way before you've waited
too long you're sleeping and sitting on
your talent
so expect to suck expect the first thing
to have zero results and you're just
paying attention to did you enjoy the
process I may have shocked at making
videos at the beginning but I liked it I
like the process and I slowly got better
and with time and effort and practice
and patience I got better 6 000 videos
later here I am with my channel and
hopefully I continue to get better but
it's always because I expect to suck at
the beginning step number two is watch
your language this is really important
you need to watch the language that you
say especially to yourself you can ask
other people to catch it for you but you
try to catch it yourself anytime you
hear yourself saying hard difficult
difficult or scary hard difficult or
scary
let that be a trigger it's a trigger
you're not allowed to say that anymore
that is not an acceptable reason for you
not to do something why are you not
going to make a video because it's hard
nope because it's difficult nope because
it's scary nope
no you do hard you do difficult you do
scary you love it you want to do hard
difficult and scary what's the opposite
the opposite of hard difficult and scary
is you do things that you are already
good at that are inside your comfort
zone
thus you hate your life if there's
nothing in your calendar for the next
week next month that is hard difficult
to scary you hate your life you're just
photocopying the same day over and over
and over and over again you want
something more you know you're capable
of something more that's how it happens
and so it's a great little acid test
it's a great reminder that every time
you hear yourself saying it it's go time
you have to go do it you have to just
because you said it and have the people
around you call you out on it too your
husband your wife your kids your friends
your family your community people around
you if you ever answer a question I'm
not gonna do it because it's hard
because it's difficult or because it's
scary it's not an acceptable answer
anymore because you do hard you do
difficult and you love scary and then
step number three is tie yourself forth
to the effort applaud the effort
regardless of the result I had a recent
podcast with my friend Mark Drager and I
asked him Mark I need you to celebrate a
point where you are part of your effort
but you didn't get a result because he's
so tied to getting results which is
great but if you only tie yourself Worth
to getting results you're going to take
small bets you're only going to play
inside your comfort zone and thus you
play small for life so I said when was
the last time that you were so proud of
your effort even though you didn't get a
result and he couldn't think of
something on the spot that's the problem
that's the problem you're not rewarding
it enough
tie your self-worth to the effort what
have you done today or what will you do
today this week this month that you're
proud of the effort even if the result
is zero even if the result is negative
you put up a video that you're you're
working your face have to try to record
and get out you spend a whole day
recording it you finally get one you
post and everybody laughs at you it's a
negative result most people probably
won't even care but let's say you get a
negative awesome I'm pumped for you
I'm pumped for you I use the example
when people are afraid to ask me
questions and workshops or seminars
um and they finally come up and they do
something
whether it's just asking a question and
Performing or making a video or or
singing or whatever their talents are
come up and do it come on up come on up
and do it and they're nervous and
they're shy and a lot of these people
have been sitting on this talent for
five ten years and they haven't
expressed it yet because I've been too
afraid and I tell them even if you come
up
and and you just vomit all over the
place
you've you vomit all over me
I am pumped for you because you tried
because you stood up and you tried
because if you got up every day and did
that and you tied yourself Worth to your
effort instead of the results the
results there are terrible right really
negative you've vomited on somebody it's
pretty bad but if you got up every day
and we're proud of your effort you got
up again and you did it again and again
and again and again I promise you get
results and way bigger results than if
you just did things that kept you in
your comfort zone rule number five the
last one before our very special bonus
clip find your core value if you want to
figure out your purpose you need to
figure out what you stand for as a human
I wrote a whole book on it it's here
it's called your one word it's about
finding your most important core value
who are you when you understand what
you're seeing the most important core
value is everything else becomes so much
easier so for me it's belief right
belief is my single most important core
value how does that help well with every
decision that I make it's seen through
the lens of belief every video content
that I make is about belief it has to be
every interaction I have every Workshop
every book every meeting all of it has
to be run through the believe framework
right the glass is a belief if I'm
hiring somebody onto my team skills
alone aren't enough it's great that you
can write copies do you believe in
entrepreneurs it's a big difference so
when you understand your core value
everything else becomes clearer and
you're less likely to follow what other
people want you to do everybody around
you they have a goal for you even if
it's well intentioned they have opinions
on what you should do with your life
everybody around you this is what you
should do with your life everybody has
an opinion you don't know which way to
go if you don't know which way to go
it's because you don't know what you
stand for because you're standing on
quicksand but when you understand your
one word you're who your most important
core value it's like you're standing on
a rock that nobody can push you from so
how do you figure that out quickly right
I mean this is 200 something Pages let's
boil it down super quick for you you
want to think about all the people that
you love your favorite teacher what you
loved about your parents think about
your favorite musician your favorite
band your favorite song your favorite
movie your favorite book all your
favorite things the thing that when you
are around consuming it reading it being
with them it makes you feel bold alive
amazing confident Unstoppable right
we've all had those moments it's just
not consistent enough yet we're gonna
make it for you it's just not consistent
enough yet and so write down a list of
five to ten things that make you come
alive again people your favorite teacher
movies all of those things that make you
that you love that you love like you
could get lost spending time with them
or reading them or listening to them
then write down three keywords that
describe each of them
so your favorite teacher why did you
love Mr Jones it's not because he taught
you grade four math right there was
something else about Mr Jones that you
love
why do I love Seabiscuit the movie
because it's about an oversized jockey
and an undersized horse and an owner
that has no money and all of these
things and they all come together it's
believe right my parents taught me that
I'm Evan because Shirley Karma because I
can do anything that I believe that I
can right and so through all the things
that I love believe is the common thread
what is it for you you have to figure it
out you have to figure it out it doesn't
have to take you years of work just
write down all of the people and the
things that you love three keywords for
each like do this this is important just
do it today it'll make a huge difference
in your life it's worth it this is the
best 15 minutes you can spend in your
life do it pause the video and do it and
then just see what comes up consistently
what word comes up over and over and
over and over and over and over again
chances are that's your one word that's
your who then when you discover it you
have to start living that life
so you know if my one word is believed
then I got to think okay who around me
is not believe what am I doing that is
not believe what projects am I working
on that are not believe and it gives you
Clarity and forces some tough decisions
and the more unhappy you are right now
in your life or business is because you
are out of alignment with your one word
if I was doing something that was
anti-belief if it even have made tons of
money I'm not going to be happy because
it's against who I am it's against my
core value same thing for you if you are
unhappy it's because you're doing things
that don't align well with your core
value and you don't know what your core
value is so fix it do the exercise
don't watch Step number two until you've
done step number one step number two is
your why so first was who next is why
your why is your purpose your purpose
comes from your pain the thing that you
struggled with the most as a human right
purpose from Pain the thing you've
struggled with the most as a human is
the thing that you want to help other
people with for life I love helping
entrepreneurs I can I can believe in
anybody I believe in people I believe
everybody has Michael Jordan level
Talent right I I believe
but I believe in entrepreneurs a lot
more why because I struggled so much as
an entrepreneur because I was making 300
bucks a month and not to survive and
doubting myself and feeling worthless as
a human being right that was me I
remember when I was 19 building up my
first company and so now my purpose is
to help other people who currently feel
that way and I love helping more
successful entrepreneurs it's fine it's
great helping people who have a million
or 10 million or even more in sales
but I'm still super connected to this to
the early stage to the start of the
person who feels not good enough that
they're not going to make it because
that's that's where I struggled that's
who I was and so whatever you struggled
with you struggled you've gone through
some pain whatever the most painful
moment was in your life not physical
pain emotional pain emotional struggle
feeling worthless why did you feel the
most worthless as a human being
the point of this isn't to inflict pain
and make you feel terrible the point is
that what whatever that moment was there
are currently there are currently tons
of people
who are going through the same thing
there are there are right now right now
many people around the world who are
going through the exact same thing that
you went through even if you're not done
climbing out of the hole you're further
ahead than where you were your purpose
for the rest of your life is to help
other people who currently are what used
to be
I had a DM from a woman on Instagram
who said The only thing that made me
come alive was a thing that destroyed my
life
the only time I felt exhilarating was it
was doing something that then destroyed
my life
and so she feels lost and no purpose
do something better the high that you
got from doing the thing that destroyed
your life there's a better High
the better high is helping people who
are currently destroying their life with
the same thing that you went through
that's fulfillment helping people get
out of the hole who are exactly like you
that's fulfillment it'll fill you up to
level I can't even explain
you'll feel so much love and explosion
inside you like this is what I'm gonna
do for the rest of my life and people
are built to serve you want to help
people it's hardwired into us right it
hits the same part of the brain as food
and sex you want to serve but how do you
serve the people who you'll serve the
most and feel the most lit up with are
the people who currently are who you
used to be and step number three is how
so who why then how step number three is
how how you got out of the problem that
you're in the big hole that you're in
how did you get out again even if you're
not totally done getting out and by the
way you're never done getting out my
biggest strength is believe and my
biggest weaknesses believe the biggest
reason why I'm not further ahead of
where I should be right now is because
of lack of belief in myself
it's my greatest strength I believe in
myself way more than I did when I was 19
or 13 or 12 or you know 28 all of it but
if 78 year old Evan came back to talk to
this version of Evan right now say your
biggest challenge you're not believing
yourself enough
it's a lifelong game it's a lifelong
journey it's great you don't want it to
end you want to grow forever but every
time you grow every time you learn every
time you get better you have a
responsibility a duty the service then
reach back and help other people climb
up one more step you take another step
up you pull somebody with you you pull
somebody else with you you pull somebody
else with you that's the process how you
got out how you saved yourself again
even if you're not done but how you got
better than where you used to be
isn't some random fluke there's a lot of
people who never figure it out
the method the way that you got out is
teachable you can help others you can
show them the path you represent hope
that it's possible and so for me it was
modeling success right the thing that
saved my business was modeling success
modeling what Bill Gates did to build
Microsoft and so what have I done for
the past 20 years is just model success
just find other people who've been doing
it and I learn and I get better and I
share that with you guys so hopefully
you can learn from people like Don napon
and you can learn from all the people
that I profile on my various channels
because I want to give the gift to you
as well I'm learning I'm getting better
and hopefully you are as well so your
how is teachable most people think their
how is just some random thing that just
happened to them and super specific and
and they can't help no no no what you
did is a recipe and that can save many
other people as well that's the process
that's how you find your purpose who I
have go through it I wrote a new book
it's called build to serve I'm going on
tour the links will put down the
description below if you want to
pre-order the book or join me on tour
but it's one of the most important
things that I think people need it's the
most common question I get asked how do
I find my passion how do I find my
purpose this is it go through the
process buy the book if you want to but
go through the process it does not have
to take years of contemplating and
thinking it doesn't have to take
thousands and thousands of dollars to
sit down with somebody to help you
figure it out that's the process go
through it it doesn't have to be hard
it's very simple the most powerful
things in the world are simple this is
your simple truth and when you discover
it it's so powerful it's so overwhelming
sometimes the gift that you could give
to the world but that becomes your duty
your obligation
you are built to serve you have a
powerful message a powerful Mission and
I want you to Discover It discover your
Michael Jordan level Talent save the
world let's do it together
happiness comes from knowing who you are
and then Having the courage and
confidence to step out onto that ledge
step out onto the ledge the ledge
and go live it and go be you because
it's hard because it's tough because
you're going to get judged because we're
constantly comparing our version of
Happiness to somebody else I'm here in
Puerto Rico Brendan burchard invited me
down to speak to his Mastermind group
these people pay 30 to 50 000 a year to
be a part of it and I'm honored to be a
guest and
the thing that I see consistently from
all the people who are here right
imagine if you're dropping 30 to 50K to
be here how much are you making
so that you want to come down right
everybody's doing the thing that makes
them come alive and that's a secret of
Entrepreneurship at least the ones who
are successful
that your version of happiness is going
to look different than somebody else's
you're a weird duck that's awesome go
live it
Brendan came on stage and started
talking about his daily routine Brandon
doesn't do anything
work related typically until about one
o'clock he wakes up he walks the beach
he meanders he plays with his cat he
does all of these things that get him in
the right mental framework and his first
call is one o'clock
so he said that I want you guys to try
something
tomorrow go and walk the beach right
walk the beach
try that first thing in the morning he
moved the start time we're supposed to
start at nine start time to ten o'clock
because he wanted us to walk the beach
this doesn't experiment to see and I I
did it I went out and walked the beach
and it was good
but it's not the thing that brings me
happiness
right living in the
Tropical Paradise
it's not my thing
I like concrete
I like the concrete jungle I like being
steps away to everything I like insane
high speed internet you know
the things that make me happy are going
to be different than Brendan Bouchard
would be different than you
I'm just about figuring out what the
heck is the thing that makes you happy
and then spending as much time as
possible doing that thing
a lot of it is still just a mind game so
how do you do it
start this process one
think about
the people in your life that make you
happy
think about the people in your life that
when you spend time with them and then
you leave you feel more energetic than
before they gave you energy as opposed
to stealing it
then the finally calls it energy
vampires the people who suck your energy
right you lead them and you feel
depleted most people are going to be the
energy vampires but you'll have some
people who are positive uplifting and
when you leave them you feel better
about yourself better about your life
more energetic ready to take on the week
ahead the day ahead the month ahead the
year ahead what have you who are those
people make a list of those people
and they try to spend more time with
them
try to find a project you can work on
together or if it's just meeting once a
month for coffee
try to spend more time with people who
lift you up and make you feel amazing
two you make a list of all the things
that make you feel happy in terms of
activities
even League of Legends let me tell you
League of Legends if you don't know
League of Legends it's a video game I've
been playing for five years I'm not
particularly good at it I don't spend
enough time on it to get amazing but I
like it I love it it's fun in my in my
downtime I'm either salsa dancing or
playing League of Legends that's it
those are my hobbies I don't cook I
don't I don't want the beach
uh I don't Garden I don't I almost do
nothing it's entrepreneurship
League of Legends and salsa dancing
that's pretty much it I could come here
to Puerto Rico and never eat in any
restaurant
the first two days before Nina came here
the first two days I had cashews and a
home Institute here
maybe not the healthiest like long-term
nutritional diet but no need to go out
and explore the different restaurants
it's
entrepreneurship
League of Legends and salsa dancing
already in that there is a level of
happiness because it's also saying no to
the things that I don't really
particularly enjoy doing I don't want to
go to karaoke I don't want to go out and
try this
other place you know I don't want to I'm
good
I'm really I'm good this is what makes
me happy
talking about League of Legends was a
little bit
shameful I think at the beginning where
say that I was playing a video game
as opposed to doing something more
valuable or meaningful with my time
but now I talked about it
I like it it's fun and if you don't
think it's fun that's awesome and if you
want to judge me for what I find fun go
for it but you've got your own thing
everybody's got their own thing that
we're embarrassed to talk about that
we're ashamed to say out loud
and you can't be happy unless you do
you know garyvee's got his Jets he's got
the garage sailing
putting out garage saleing videos he got
judged a lot more
from his friends
you've got something like that too
I've got League of Legends
and so Having the courage to then say
this is me and to share it and to be
okay with it and to not be embarrassed
by it
Having the courage to go off and
actually start living that life to do it
to go and do it
feel good about yourself that's where
the happiness comes from
and third I would say make sure that
you're consuming content that makes you
feel happy
you know these videos I've gotten so
much from Gary I've gotten so much from
other people I've profiled and makes me
feel happier makes me feel more alive
you know a lot I'm not hanging with Gary
every weekend you're not hanging with me
every weekend but you can get
videos
and you can remind yourself that this
world exists
and you want to play in it more often as
opposed to where you are because where
you are right now is where you want to
be and that's okay you don't have to
stay where you are forever
and so the things that will get you out
the things that will lead to the
ultimate happiness
is figuring out one what makes you happy
right I mean it's not the beach
isn't it I don't want to live here it's
great it's beautiful amazing but I don't
wanna I don't wanna
I think those people hanging out on the
beach there with the umbrellas I think
they're nuts awesome go do you it's not
for me I understand what makes you happy
hanging around with people who make you
happy
do the activities that make you happy
consume the videos content resources
that make you happy
start now
because you deserve to be happy
because you made it this far in a video
I want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but
you're different you are special believe
Nation you made it here all the way to
the end and I love you so it's a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments Below on this video
I will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome and if you
want to watch Evan's top 10 rules for
Success check out the video next to me I
think you can enjoy continue typically I
will see you there just cut out the
people who don't serve you sometimes
those are friends that you've had from
kindergarten or high school or
university you're in the Friendship out
of convenience now there's a lot of
people who you might need to let go of
you might need to just let them go